[Music]
if then we allow that it is this highest
good that essentially matters then
consciousness is not an earnest with
morality at all for in this highest good
nature does not have a different law
from that of morality
hence moral action itself is ruled out
for action takes place only on the
assumption of a negative which is to be
set aside by the action but if nature is
in conformity with the moral law the
latter would in fact be violated by the
setting aside of what is in existence in
the assumption that the highest good is
what essentially matters there is
admitted a situation in which moral
action is superfluous and does not take
place at all the postulate of the
harmony of morality and reality a
harmony posited by the notion of moral
action which implies bringing the two
into agreement is expressed from this
point of view - in the form because
moral action is the absolute purpose the
absolute purpose is that there should be
no such thing as moral action
paragraph 620 is a relatively short
paragraph and it is consolidating what
has been going on in the first four
paragraphs two of which were quite long
of this new section which is translated
here by Miller as decembe lengths or
duplicity just one German term for the
whole thing fare Stalin which if you
know your German is going to be already
bound up with some some similarly
sounding things that Hegel makes use of
all the time forced along there all
right and here Hegel is going to lead us
to a paradoxical conclusion you know
this is where again I've pointed this
out many times in the course of this
commentary we should be really really
wary of the notion of hegelian dialectic
as this you know three step shuffle that
people put it forward thesis antithesis
synthesis sometimes it is much much much
more complicated than that and this is a
good example complicated in two senses
there is no nice easy progress from
thesis antithesis synthesis in much of
the dialectic because it often ends up
in what appeared to be a poor really
that is places where you you know
literally in Greek you go in and you
can't get out of problems roadblocks
obstacles and and this statement at the
end of it because moral action is the
absolute purpose the absolute purpose is
that there should be no such thing as
moral action is precisely one of those
now when you read that and we'll come
back to this a little bit more in the
end when you read that it has the sort
of semblance again decembe lence the
sort of things that gurus often say all
right they just you know transpose
things if X is y then Y is the real ax
or
if X is y then X is the fact that there
never really is a Y and we can go on and
on with these formula Hegel's not doing
that this represents a genuine movement
of thought and it's more complex than
just having you know one idea in place
and then it's opposite and then you know
bringing them together in some sort of
synthesis as we've noted instead there
is something that that has more moving
parts in involved although Hegel does
like to look at things in terms of dyads
doesn't it I think in part because that
allows him to keep it relatively simple
when he's dealing with these incredibly
complex social realities and realities
of developing consciousness so all that
said what is this highest good that he's
referencing here the hoax the good right
that essentially matters he says if we
allow that it is the highest good that
essentially matters here he's saying
that that is the essence that is what
has the importance that is taking on the
initiative here
what is this highest good we're gonna
see in just a moment consciousness he
says is not in earnest with morality at
all so if we make this highest good what
is absolutely essential the center of
what it is that we're studying then
there's a problem in how consciousness
is understanding morality it's not an
earnest about it and you might say it's
not in earnest through it because we're
not simply talking about a consciousness
that cognizes and thinks out morality
right you might be tempted when you're
reading this section to think you know
this is all dealing with Conte and his
understanding of duty and morality and
nature and happiness and that's not
off-base except with the only part there
but when you read can't say second
critique or you read the groundwork for
the metaphysics of morals or you
actually go on and read the metaphysics
of morals metaphysical elements of
justice metaphysical elements of
you you find that it's very theoretical
isn't it this is not just a theorizing
consciousness that's stepping back in an
ethics class trying to make sense of
what would our obligations be this is a
consciousness that is out there in the
world trying to figure out how to live
the best life how to put itself in touch
with what is most essential how to
embody or at least be in some sort of
connection with the highest good and
that is being understood here in terms
of morality and moral duty as well as of
course nature happiness drives
inclination Zahl of those sorts of
things which we hope can be incorporated
but at this point they can't so he says
in this highest good nature does not
have a different law from that of
morality so that's what we you know
we've talked about this already and the
other paragraphs but that's what we
begin from in this paragraph Nature has
its own law its own system of
regularities of cause and effect how
things happen in this entire realm that
we call nature which includes not only
the natural world but also us as
psychophysical beings and as social
beings who have some sort of you could
call them social or psychological laws
that don't perhaps govern us entirely
but certainly conditioned us much of the
time and then we have morality and we
could say does morality really have a
law or isn't morality itself a law if
we're adopting in the Koch in
perspective of course kind of this is
one of his great you could say one of
his great achievements in terms of the
history of ethics is thinking through
this idea of an identification of
morality not just with laws but with law
as such you might say law likeness or
not I would say legality although that
has the wrong sort of implication the
case of what is required
to be a law to be a genuine law and
nature and morality somehow are
harmonized so that they're not lacking
this interface in the law now this is
postulated right this is not something
that we actually do observe in nature
but it is something that we can think we
can imagine a society in which everybody
every human being let's leave all the
other animals and growing things of
nature out of it but in which every
human being somehow is brought to
recognize the moral law in its fullness
in its totality perhaps in a
developmental way and because they
recognize it they are properly motivated
by it their drives their inclinations
towards happiness whatever that happens
to be can't remember to find happiness
is the satisfaction of all of our
desires and inclinations those are all
oriented in the right way to achieve the
ends or the goal or the purpose of
morality now what is the upshot of this
Hegel says this rules out moral action
moral honden or Han lung right the not
just acting at one point not just the
taught the deed but acting in a
consistent way we could think of this as
moral comportment becomes impossible as
well now why does this mean that we no
longer act we no longer comport
ourselves we no longer have styles of
approach to life no it's it's not that
it's just that it no longer is moral so
the action is you could say besides the
point it loses its meaning then this is
a big problem why he says that action
takes place why do we act in the first
place why do we behave that's another
way of translating handled all right
action takes place only on the
assumption of something negative a
at vos- as' and here this setting aside
Hegel uses the term you know off to
haben in here Alf haben right that zu is
just a part of the thing that gets
interjected there's a particle that you
need in the German in order to make this
sentence work so Alf haben the process
of sublation here it's being translated
as merely setting setting aside but you
could think about this in every moral
action there is a taking the raw
material that you have in front of you
which is usually quite messy and often
quite screwed up and you are
transforming it you are incorporating it
you are throwing parts of it away
and you're keeping other parts of it and
you're incorporating them into a greater
whole which is the moral action or the
line of behavior comportment that you
are yourself engaging in that is part of
what makes it moral action you have to
strive you have to rise above you have
to exert agency in relation to a world
that is not rewarding you and not
motivating you to do the right thing so
if the world is already doing that for
you it seems like you can't actually
engage in moral action and this whole
setting a side thing this of Haven of
hey bung in this this passage is how
he's talking about it of what exists the
Zion does the the thing that has being
they can't really take place can it you
only have how things actually are and
although you know maybe your teacher
will give you a sticker or gold star for
being a good boy or good girl it really
doesn't matter it's deprived of its
meaning isn't it
so he says if nature is in conformity
with the moral law then the moral law
would be violated by the setting aside
of what is in existence so what
allows us to act in a moral way the fact
that there isn't a perfect coincidence
between these two but here we're
postulating that there is this harmony
or a coincidence between the two so he
says that the postulate of the harmony
of morality and reality right
a harmony posited by the notion of moral
action the concept the beginning of
moral action which implies bringing the
two into agreement where we're having
that as an end that is what we're trying
to do we're trying to make the world a
better place
we're trying to make the world in some
respect the reality that we're dealing
with map on to what the ideal morality
would be requiring of it but it's not
yet there when we postulate that we are
in effect saying that it's already there
and just has to be realized by us we're
sort of placing ourself on the the right
side of history as people say and as
soon as you start talking about things
that way people get very worked up and
then they very quickly lose their
enthusiasm about that because hell if
I'm on the right side of history already
what does it matter if I put myself into
it what does it matter if I struggle
against my inclinations why not just do
what comes naturally to me right so he
goes on and this is where we get to the
end he says that expressed from this
point of view we can have it in this
form because moral action is the
absolute purpose and we saw that moral
action is the absolute purpose it's not
just about having morality out there as
a set of standards it's about
consciousness practically reasoning its
way through its life and living in
accordance with morality choosing in
accordance with morality making morality
happen through moral actions so because
moral action is the absolute purpose the
absolute purpose now we get this
paradoxical resolution is that there
should be no such thing as moral action
if we succeed in changing
human nature so that we automatically AC
and accept the good we wouldn't actually
have moral action so this is a bit of a
conundrum is it
when we put together these moments which
consciousness is traversed in its ideas
of morality it is clear that each one
internists superseded in its opposite
consciousness starts from the idea that
for it morality and reality do not
harmonize but it is not in earnest about
this for in the deed the presence of
this harmony becomes explicit for it but
it is not an earnest even about this
deed since the deed is something
individual for it has such a high
purpose the highest good but this again
is only add assemblance of the facts for
such decembe lence would do away with
all action and all morality in other
words consciousness is not strictly
speaking in earnest with moral action
what it really holds to be most
desirable to be the absolute is that the
highest could be accomplished and that
moral action be superfluous
if paragraphs 620 brought things to a
kind of head paragraph 621 is
consolidating the movements that have
been carried out now in this section and
also in the section of morality
preceding this the moral view of the
world and Hegel has a lot of interesting
plays on words going on in here
centering around this whole notion of
Stalin to put in place and that is going
to play a role here with with two
different prefixes for and here the
difference between them just being one
letter the vowel and if we wanted to be
really clever we could say you know that
maybe there's some sort of vowel change
process or umlaut and taking place here
although there really isn't but there is
a play going on between for Stalin or
for Stalin representation ways in which
consciousness in here is presenting
things to itself and fear Stalin or fear
Stalin the act or the process of
duplicity or decembe once right framing
things is another way of translating and
substituting you could even say and so
Hegel begins this this paragraph by
saying when we put together these
moments when we Stalin the moment the
the different passages that we've seen
the different dynamics that are going on
the different resting points when we set
them all out for ourselves in a kind of
tableau when we bring them before
consciousness in that way whether in a
graphic way say using a blackboard or a
piece of paper or reading them in the
text itself or visualizing these in our
own minds setting them out
he says consciousness has traversed
these in its ideas of morality
he says it's clear that each one is
superseded
in its opposite and so each of these
representations you could say each of
these positions of consciousness there
is a process of Super Session or I'll
table that's going on but it's not an
out hey bong of something else rather it
is it is sub lading itself and leading
into its opposite so consciousness is
watching this take place but
consciousness is also the agent of this
consciousness is leading the process and
consciousness is not just interested as
I said many times in this as a
theoretical prat exercise it's got
practical implications and this has to
do with how consciousness situates
itself in the world as moral
consciousness as an agent so he says
each of these is superseded in its
opposite what happens consciousness
starts out from the idea that for it for
consciousness morality and reality do
not harmonize you might say well that's
kind of a trivial result isn't it I mean
is there even morality and reality for
something that isn't consciousness no
unless you think that the morality sort
of exists out there totally disconnected
from any sort of consciousness just
waiting for us to discover it but Hegel
doesn't really think that morality is a
human way of understanding the cosmos
and itself and the relation between the
two
so reality vir cleek kites and morality
don't map on to each other there's a
dissonance between them for
consciousness oh well we've realized
this right that's a starting point and
we can we don't have to read content
understand that all you have to do is be
a kid and see that something is unfair
and be told something like life isn't
fair or that's the way it works in these
sort of situations or just shut up and
sit down and don't ask any more
questions like that and you start to
realize right off the bat in a very
practical way that there is a non
coincidence at best and maybe a jarring
chasm between morality and reality and
then the question is well what do we
want to do with this do we want to make
reality more moral do we want to try to
change things for the better well that
leads us through this out of a bong the
sublation into the next for stella the
next representation so he says here we
go consciousness is not really earnest
about this first starting point for in
the deed and deed here is translating
Hans lung right so in the action in the
comportment and the thing that you
choose to do in the mode of behavior
then we find that there is a presence of
harmony brought about why you do
something and if it's a moral act you're
doing something that actually produces a
greater amount at least in that little
corner of the world that you're
concerned with the little scope that you
have some agency in you're producing a
new harmony or coincidence between the
ideal and the real between morality and
how things are what would be an example
of this well you know you think that
it's important to help people out who
are down on their luck you walk past a
homeless person you're not sure how
they're gonna spend the money but they
ask you for a dollar and you say it's
your lucky day here's five why don't you
go get yourself to eat something to eat
and maybe they spend it on you know a
flask of cheap you know liquor or maybe
they go and they buy themselves
something to eat maybe it transforms
their life probably not but
you know they're like well somebody
actually believed in me and helped me
out in this case maybe they go and they
share it with others you don't actually
control that part but what you do
control is that little portion of the
world where you instead of saying sorry
screw you I've got nothing for you or
get a job or something like that you
adopt a different handling you adopt a
different point of view and you
transform a bit of reality in the
process not in a way that you totally
control the results but you do produce a
small area of coincidence between
morality and reality and we do this over
and over and over again what if you do a
non moral or or anti moral action an
immoral action what if the person asks
you for you know something to purchase
food with and you go and you kick him
instead all right
you exert violence on them well that's
you know in a way you're showing them
that reality is even more screwed up
further away from the moral norm than
you thought and you're damaging that
portion of reality and you're also
damaging yourself you're also making
yourself into a worse person I mean I
don't think this should be particularly
controversial if you're going around
kicking homeless people asking for
change you've got some real problems you
know you may justify it to yourself in
some sort of well you know it's cosmic
justice or something like that but
that's probably you lying to yourself
let's be quite honest about that right
so in the deed there is brought about a
presence and actually present
Gagan part of the harmony between
morality and reality so now we've got a
new representation a new force telling
and then Hegel says yeah but
consciousness is not really even in
earnest about that why because when it
starts thinking it that out the deed is
something individual now we pass on to
the third force telling the deed is
something individual it has such a high
purpose the purpose of the highest good
it has an aim as
the highest good and he says this again
is only a dis semblance and now we get
that that word coming up right there
steadily it's setting things out but
it's doing so in a way that conceals or
is is you know deceiving a way that's
going to delude the outside observer and
perhaps even the self you engage in
fierce telling so that you can tell
yourself that you're a great guy that
you're a perfect person that you're in
touch with the beautiful the true the
good you're embodying that in the world
right that's a fair stone and so he goes
on and he says that this is a
dissembling so the facts for such
decembe lence why would do away not just
with all action but here he also says
with all morality it would do away both
with the thing that allows morality to
be brought into the world to have agency
and morality itself and it would leave
only what would be the residue there
would be vir clicked actuality the world
as it as it is and some people say that
would be great get rid of all this moral
humbug and nonsense but is that really
what you would want he goes on and he
says in other words consciousness is not
strictly speaking in earnest with moral
action as such what it really holds to
be most desirable to be the absolute is
that the highest good be accomplished
and that moral action be superfluous
what it's really aiming at is the
highest good itself and some sort of
condition in which we wouldn't even
really need action because we just sort
of follow along so we're going to see
whether this can actually work or not
for consciousness or whether it's you
might say a bad fit
you